Roseanne went on Tim Poole's podcast
yesterday with Michael malice who's a
many-time guest of the Reuben report and
they started talking about this divide
two and a bit about how we get past it
oh it's just so scary and horrible I I
just I'm so afraid I just have to say
I'm so afraid what what are you afraid
of what's happening to our country and
how divided we are how we can't get how
we can't get together to make it better
for all of us we just yeah but we'll go
down fighting each other but when the
government owners are getting richer and
uh it's just on but but Roseanne look at
her way when the government gets
together it screws over the middle class
for in the favor of people of political
access and power well that's what I'm
saying I'm scared of that and how bad
it's going to get regular people so how
do we know that this cultural crossover
is legit first off you've got like you
know major Hollywood sitcom Stars
sitting down with anarchists at Tim
Poole's House in West Virginia like
something about all of that it's just
like there's something bubbling up I
felt this years ago I'm feeling it again
I know this thing is real
[Music]
foreign